Festival of harmony and friendship of 4.5 billion Asians: Incheon Asian Games.
For 16 days from September 19th to October 4th,...
...the national teams of 45 Asian countries...
...participate in 36 sports entries, competing for medals.
Under the slogan of "Diversity Shines Here,"...
...about 13,000 athletes and officials will be together.
Samsung will be there for Incheon Asian Games,...
...the festival where diverse cultures and traditions of Asia shine and share.
Since Bangkok Asian Games in 1998, Busan Asian Games in 2002,...
...Doha Asian Games in 2006, Guangzhou Asian Games in 2010...
...and this Incheon Asian Games,...
...Samsung has supported Asian Games as prestige partner five times in a row,...
...which is the longest record.
The festival of harmony and peace for Asians united.